alright let's find an angle that I'm
happy with but that that should do it
I think anyways for a high angle this
time not sure why actually let's bring
that down a little one of these days
I'll actually start this thing and just
start it as opposed to fiddle with the
camera for like the first minute but
today is not that day alrighty so in
case folks either don't know how to
decide for the title of this thing or
miss the the Twitter clarification um oh
goodness
excuse me topic this week is YouTube and
youtubing and how I approach this thing
that apparently I do
and also drinking question in addition
to the usual standards is uh hey what
are your thoughts on the spider-man
movie thing so if anyone is wondering
video tomorrow I am moving the the
Doctor Who overdue reviewed a Friday
which I don't like doing but that's
that's what it's gonna be it isn't an
official livestream without technical
difficulties so very very true what's on
your mug oh the mug there you go
oh and the the other thing I mentioned
just to mention it up top before I start
digging into what is actually gonna be
the topic too much ah there it is
everybody drink video tomorrow but I
have I watched the Rocko's Modern Life
um special static cling I'm not gonna do
a video on it
I by the time it was done I just don't I
don't have much to say I realized as I
was watching I'm like oh yeah I never
really got into this show and as it went
along I was reminded of all the reasons
why it was never really my thing so I
can't really judge it as a as a revival
of the show because I'm not a fan of the
original show I know the show has its
fans I'm not gonna say it's a bad show
it just it was never for me and then you
know as far as the trans elements of it
I thought they were handled perfectly
fine that's kind of all I've got to say
on that Oh somebody's requiring
technical assistance what's happening
what's going on I really like the next
the let's play of newfound cards that's
good cuz there's gonna be more parts to
that what are your thoughts on lgbtq+
creators suing youtube i was not aware
that that was a thing so you're gonna
have to Wow I was gone I was gonna say
fill me in on that but I have a feeling
there's probably more to it then I'd be
able to get from a chat comment oh thank
you very much Mike what do you think
about the Heymann Netflix anime
announced over the weekend I am curious
so the thing with that if people miss it
and I did tweet on this um Netflix is
going to be doing a he-man show before
sheer our fans get all excited it is
to cross over because apparently this is
going to be even though the visual style
is changing because they're getting the
studio that take Castlevania so it's
gonna be anime style but narrative Lee
is going to be picking up where the
original he-man series left off with
those same characters it's gonna be it's
gonna have Kevin Smith as the showrunner
and it's I'm really curious I want to
see trailer that's basically my thing
like on those things I'm like okay let's
see what it is have you seen any more of
Jessica Jones season 3 nope
it's only just the first episode go to
what's the safe word to see the video
about LGBTQ suing YouTube I'm gonna have
to do that after the live stream I think
just because I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
make everybody wait while I do research
a new drinking game do you remember the
end of he-man I'm not sure I ever saw
the last episode actually so anyways um
getting onto the supposed primary topic
this thing that I do I wanted for a
while to sort of talk about how I
approached YouTube and all the stuff
that just goes on with it but I could
never figure out a format to do it and I
because I know I don't know what
questions people would actually have
versus what I would just you know think
people would want to hear from me so I
figured a more active Q&A sort of
session would make a lot more sense to
try and tackle this sort of thing Thank
You Meg good see you tonight have you
gotten a chance to watch infinity train
yet I have not I have not the whole
series takes near 90 minutes to finish
it's such a well-made fantasy sci-fi
show oh that's it um I will try and
carve out time this week
no promises I've got a lot on my plate
but I will try favorite type of
oh um you'll forgive me for not
answering that one what do you think
about spider-man be pulled out of the
MCU there it is again everybody drink a
video on that tomorrow does a sly
extreme hurt your YouTube stats um so
far as I can tell no um if if they were
I would have figure out a different way
to do this I mean there are some
channels that that have like a
completely separate thing for their live
streams and I considered doing that but
I I think it's only when like you're
really big that the differential between
what you get on on a live stream versus
a normal video actually starts hurting
you and I'm not big enough for that to
happen how close are you to be able to
do YouTube full-time and quit your day
job um if I really really tighten my
belt maybe a half way and when I say
that that's based both off of what I get
through YouTube and also patreon if both
of those doubles then I think I might
just barely be able to make it it's it's
tough I'm my uh my channel and also the
patreon support is is of a size that
somebody with less riding on their
ability to make their monthly bills
might do the leap and and you know quit
their day job and make it go at it to
devote full time and see if they could
give it that push that it needs I'm not
going to do that um I need I need
everything to get to the point where
it's already gonna I'm already gonna be
okay
before I can safely quit my job I can't
like do a leap of faith to cover a gap
because it's not just about me I have a
family I have a kid I have people
dependent on me so I've got a lot to
lose if I quit my job and this doesn't
work so if I was younger you know didn't
have the same responsibilities maybe I
may be the lead case where I could quit
my job now and hope that devoting full
time would you know allow me to do the
things I need to do to push it further
faster but that's just kind of where it
is right now what would you say is your
favorite book by dr. Seuss at this point
I'm partial to I trouble in getting
solace to the solace of Lou cuz it's the
one my daughter asked me to read the
most so I have a lot of fun reading that
one have you watched the third and last
season of lijing yet no god I haven't
even started it there's so much stuff
I'm behind on right now it's like taking
a week vacation and then taking a
three-day weekend to do terrific on
really put me behind in turn well no
I'll retract that I'm not behind but it
killed my cushion I used to have a
cushion of like I being a week or two
ahead in terms of stuff and I'm not
anymore now I really need to just you
know scramble scramble scramble to get
stuff out on time and try and rebuild
that cushion so time for stuff just for
fun is very very limited
thoughts on spider-man leaving the MCU
everybody drink video tomorrow ah
there's a new Matrix movie being made
what are your thoughts on it um I'm more
interested since lana wachowski is being
involved Lily's apparently not working
on it but having one of them involved
perks my interests a lot more because up
to this point it looked like it was
gonna happen regardless and both of
which have skis they kind of said that
they were going into semi-retirement
so having Lana involved makes me more
interested than I would have been
otherwise because as much as yo there
are issues with the Matrix sequels I
think the idea of I'm pretty sure Warner
Brothers has the rights on these the
idea of them just doing whatever they
want with no one
from the original creative team that
that would really make me nervous
I was able to get a Hamilton ticket I'm
seeing in October I'm very lucky if you
ever hypothetically did quit your job
for YouTube would you choose to do
bigger projects or daily videos um
bigger projects what so like I have it
in my head what my day would be like if
I was able to have my full-time job be
this because there are a number of
things that it would enable to me to do
so like in my thoughts on Marvel I'm
spider-man leaving the MCU everybody
drank video tomorrow so in my mind I
would I would still be putting in a full
8-hour day of working and I'd start I
you know get up I have coffee and then I
would do three hours of writing and of
whatever whether it is writing a script
for a future video revising scripts
working on a piece of fiction or
something three hours of writing like
two hours of viewing and note-taking for
whatever it is that I'm with two hours
of either shooting new stuff or watching
stuff that I need to in order to create
content and then wrap out the last three
hours of the day with just editing and
in my mind I would keep I would keep the
four videos a week schedule um but I
would start having some of those videos
be bigger projects be things that
involve a lot more editing a lot more
elaborate shooting maybe locations maybe
a different set than just this that's
the kind of stuff that I would love to
do if I had the time and I just don't
right now thank you very much Meg how
would you try to fix the YouTube
copyright laws the I don't know because
the problem is the best things that
could be done to fix them require
amount of manpower that simply is not
reasonable because YouTube and Google
might theoretically have all the money
in the world but there's only so many
people you can hire to do the things
that would need to be done to do it
properly because the best thing to do
would be to force anyone trying to make
a copyright claim to prove they had
ownership of the thing before they
before that claim actually went through
I'm not even talking about strikes I
actually have never had to deal with a
copyright strike but it would it would
be nice and these people had to prove
that they actually held the copyright to
these things but they don't which is a
big part of which is part of the initial
problem which is basically that anybody
can issue a copyright claim now I it
seems to be changing but there also
isn't a lot of punishment for issuing
spurious claims um I think they crack
down on like individuals who it turns
out didn't have any rights to claim at
all but like corporations there is
nothing that is done against them if
they make claim after claim after claim
after claim and it then again is
determined to be free use every single
time they suffer no consequences for
that they disrupt the YouTuber and
suffer no consequences it's why they
claim as much as they do it's still
better than it was certainly in terms of
what happens with the revenue but it's
it's messed up
and some are better than others
depending on on just their attitude and
how they approach it because some
copyright holders are absolute pricks
and some are pretty chill and it really
is a case-by-case basis any tips for not
getting to focus on numbers and losing
sight of having fun tips on it no you do
have to do it I mean my honest
suggestion is first of all you shouldn't
really be looking at your analytics if
you're if you're not at least 500
subscribers I would say a thousand
because analytics when
when you're dealing with numbers that
low aren't useful because literally five
more people watch your watch a video and
suddenly you know it it's it's a
significant percentage of what your
subscriber base is and it makes the
analytics go all over the place so
honestly I shouldn't be looking at
numbers at all and for a while how do
you decide who is a moderator or guest
etc on the channel a certain degree of
trust I have one moderator in this chat
it's actually the very first time that
I've tried having a moderator so we'll
see how it goes nope no pressure um so
you know it's it's not something that I
hand out willy-nilly it's something I'm
very very cautious about did you finally
see did you finally see the new video
that Lindsey Ellis did on Game of
Thrones yeah I did
it was good I mean she does really good
stuff it was good and it was funny and
it was well thought out I didn't agree
with her assessment wit of every
character that she sort of went on the
went over issues with but I can't say
she was wrong about really any of it
a while back I came across this really
overlooked animated feature from 2011
it's a hungarian film called trad the
tragedy of man it's absolute spectacle
of genius and depth hmm Adam thought of
that one boss on YouTube discussing
possibly removing the dislike button I
don't think it matters cuz at this point
the dislike button doesn't actually hurt
you because it still counts as
engagement so like a high dislike to
like percentage that's basically
information for the the video maker and
they decide how much stock they put into
it there was a time once upon a time
where a high dislike thing actually
meant something it doesn't really
anymore at least as far as we're able to
figure out the algorithm cuz that's the
big thing you need to realize anything I
say relating to the algorithm is
presumption because YouTube does
tell us what the algorithm is and how it
works and I get why they don't because
the instant people know how the system
works they can figure out how to cheat
it and how to you know fake things that
you know create things that will please
the algorithm but are not actually
quality content that anybody wants
that's how like three or four years ago
we had lots of incredibly bizarre
supposing kids things that were like
these weird basic Microsoft moviemaker
stiff 3d CGI things moving around with
like spider-man and Elsa and she was
pregnant like stuff like that wasn't
around because it knew how to game the
algorithm as it existed so as much as it
frustrates me that they changed the
algorithm and don't tell us I also get
it because when the platform is this
open and there's no barrier to entry to
get to start putting stuff up then you
can't just tell people how the system
works because there'll be too many bad
actors who will just cheat the system
who will figure out how to do it and
then just do it how was your time on a
scree Perce podcast it wasn't bad I got
to get a better mic for that though um
cuz I did not love like my my end of the
audio was not great quality I feel
actually really bad about that any tips
for how to format reviews on my channel
I mainly review Big Finish content and
my reviews are mainly recaps of a plot
while I list what I like versus what I
don't like well when you do something
like baby finish which you can't
necessarily count on a ton of people
having read or heard that's probably a
really good approach to it
now I do things a little bit different
with a lot of reviews that I do because
most of the stuff that I review unless
otherwise noted
I'm usually presuming that my audience
has seen it already um that's obviously
I assume that to be the case with the
over to doctor who reviews I assume that
to be the case with the majority of
movie reviews that I do for like Marvel
and whatever because you know I'm not a
professional critic I'm not getting to
see these things prior to release so
I'm getting videos out a few days after
release and I figure anybody who really
cared about it will have already seen it
and so my approach to reviews is very
much in that vein I will still point out
specific plot points that I want to
bring up and I'll give a warning before
I get into flat-out spoilers I don't
usually do plot recaps but again it's
primarily because most of the stuff I'm
talking about review wise I presume the
audience kind of has some familiarity
with it if they don't I'll go more out
of my way to figure out how to synopsize
the plot you usually giving the initial
pitch of the thing to talk about the
broad strokes and then warning about
going to spoilers and then from there I
just treated like they've already seen
it and proceed accordingly I don't
usually look at analytics but I can't
help going that didn't even crack 50
views okay so let me let me just talk
about the the sort of metric I use for
myself in terms of views and gauging how
successful any given video was now the
first thing that I'm gonna say is what
I'm about to say is specific to me and
how I approach this this is not gonna be
true of of absolutely everybody and
depending on the format of a channel
they may treat things very differently
but here's the baseline that I use as
someone who's put out regular content
content you know multiple videos a week
because I would say it's very different
for somebody who does a very lavish
production once a month you know your
philosophy tubes and your conscience and
your Lindsay Ellis and Patrick Williams
and folks like that that everything I'm
about to say doesn't really apply to
that kind of approach yeah the really
big deal but less frequently release but
if you're doing a more steady sort of
output my baseline sort of looking at it
through the lens of like a job
performance
you know meets expectations below
expectations exceeds expectations maybe
you're lucky greatly exceeds
expectations so meeting expectations to
me is any video that is able to capture
views equal to 10% of my subscriber base
within the first 24 hours of going up so
right now that means roughly thirty
seven hundred views in the first 24
hours that for me meets expectations
it's not like amazing I'm not doing a
party but I'm also not like oh no what
went wrong there it's fine that's like C
plus B minus sort of range I'm sorry I'm
just popular what format a Big Finish in
art they novels no their audio
adventures so you buy them and you
listen to them super boring boring
question what editing software do you
use I currently use pinnacle which I
switched to because when my I use
Pinnacle Studio 20 I switched to late no
not late last year early 2017 because
I've been using
[Music]
Adobe Premiere Elements for years and
the software started to completely fall
apart in a way that to me said this was
designed to start failing after a while
and forced me to upgrade and I felt very
because things started going wrong with
it that had never been the case up to
that point and I got very bitter or
refused to upgrade with Adobe again now
next time I I need to maybe I will go
back to Adobe the pickle pinnacles fine
and I like it but you know I'm probably
liable to bounce back and forth anyways
coming back to what I was saying so my
normal baseline for meets expectations
10% of my subscriber base in views
within the first 24 hours anything that
is around half that that to me is like
oh that was a soft landing anything that
like big like either barely or fails to
crack thousand views at this point in
the first 24 hours that to me says maybe
I don't do that topic again now there's
a little bit of an x-factor in this
because I do have the commission to
reviews through patreon and those I
don't worry about the views so much
because I
got paid up front for that so from a
strictly financial point I can afford
for the video not to do exceptionally
well um that said I still try and space
those out and do no more than two a
month if it's like outside my wheelhouse
and I don't expect the video of you to
be especially big because if you're
doing a regular output of something
that's underperforming relative to the
other stuff that will hurt you
but on the other end of things so on the
high end anything that even hits at this
point even half of my subscriber base
I'm very happy that thrills me and
anything that and it like even beyond
the first 24 hours anything that in a
total view count meets or exceeds my
subscriber numbers I'm thrilled
like that's viral in my world real viral
by YouTube standards is a million views
are better in my little corner in my
little world anything where the views
are higher than my total subscriber
numbers that is viral to me the other
thing to mention about subscribers
versus view number do not assume that
every subscriber you have is going to
watch every video you should never take
your subscriber numbers up as oh I'll
have that many views every time I put
out a video not if you're doing multiple
videos a week that may be the case more
like I said with the people who do the
big you know video essays more the big
productions maybe one a month because
their releases are such big to dues then
in their cases oftentimes yes they do
meet or exceed their subscriber numbers
in views on every video but they're also
putting out way fewer videos and if any
of those videos don't hit those numbers
that's actually gonna potentially impact
them quite a bit so you know it's a
balance between what you want to do with
your channel cuz always have an eye on
what you actually enjoy doing cuz you
need to enjoy this even if you're not
grow even if you're not making money
because otherwise you're gonna burn out
and you know figuring out the the
balance of gains to losses because
anyone who says I don't pay attention to
views and clicks at all like liar
if any question any late bloomers in
your catalog videos that grew on later
um yes I'm having a hard time thinking
of any office on my head but there have
been some that like you know had their
initial release went very dormant and
then popped up again later it happens
sporadically with various videos i again
i can't think of us specific one off the
top of my head it's worth mentioning
that horton hears a who just turns 65
years old well happy birthday to horton
no thoughts on the spider-man so any
marvel's situation everybody drink video
tomorrow
besides the show big finish what else is
there are they all canon there's comic
books
there's novels there's video games and
they are canon unless the show
contradicts them basically the ultimate
canon is the show the various other
things usually try to stay canon but the
show isn't keeping track of everything
else so the show's gonna do its own
thing and if it contradicts something
that was done and the other stuff then
you can now consider that to not be
canon but unless it's been contradicted
by the show most people take it as can
so hold on i'm gonna pop why address the
sony marvel situation if it's just a
rumor because it's actually got more
backing and has reporting from more
reliable sources than most of the stuff
I'm prepared to dismiss as a rumor it's
got better sourcing so usually when I
say rumor I don't want to talk about a
rumor it's because if I track something
back to a source it's literally like
someplace going hey I heard this and
it's like a site I've never heard of or
Channel I don't know but like the
original stars on this was deadline and
they're pretty good like they're not
always right but they're pretty good in
terms of their sourcing and they're
vetting what they put out there so I do
believe that what they put out is act
at this moment in time again video
tomorrow from life from my full thoughts
ah in my opinion the best animated film
I've seen from 2008 is Israeli
documentary called waltz with bashir
I've heard of waltz with bashir I
haven't seen it I did see what was it
the Congress I think it was which was
the next movie the the same director
made that was a weird film I think I
liked it but it was weird I haven't seen
waltz with bashir though would you be
interested in seeing the return of the
valued not really I never found the
value are to be all that compelling like
if they wanted to do something like the
value or what makes the most sense to me
would be to bring back the meta-crisis
doctor and have that be the value art
except I'm not saying I actually want
them to do that because to do that and
the gates Roses happy ending and that's
kind of a big middle finger to people
who would like to that so I just don't
find the value at that compelling same
thing I had same reason I don't really
care if the rani ever comes back do you
think the next fantastic beast movie
will finally have proper gay inclusion
in it with Dumbledore I have no idea I
hope so
because at this point like it's it has
become it's be what's the word it's
become conspicuous by its absence at
this point like at this point if they
don't do it in the third film then
there's nothing there's no reason that
they can give to justify it at this
point so um I hope it's the air only so
I can stop shouting about that I dislike
the fantastic beasts movies enough that
I don't have a lot of confidence that
the next one is gonna be any good but I
would like them to at least do that so I
can stop
freaking being mad about it I don't want
to be mad about that I would like to
stop now hello what are we talking about
well primarily YouTube um but we're kind
of jumping all over the place as we tend
to do do you plan on watching they're
doing a video on invader zim entered the
floor but I might watch it video is
doubtful unless it really blows me away
that said I liked invader zim more than
I liked Rocko's Modern Life so there's a
better chance that I'll like it but I've
also kind of grown out of invader zim
like I tried to rewatch some of it I'm
like I know why I used to like this but
it's not really clicking for me anymore
I think I'm just aged out of it if I'm
being completely honest which is weird
for me because a lot of stuff I've loved
since I was young that I know is stupid
in for kids I still enjoy but for some
reason that one didn't quite carry over
for me I've been into Doctor Who for a
few years I absolutely love it
council Games was the first person I
found him share my love of it oh thanks
Brittany what one time Doctor Who
villain would you like to see returned
in the future not allowed to say mr.
Finch we all know you love him oh yeah
that was gonna be my big one ah the
dream master don't care how you bring
him back just bring him back alright
your hair's looking amazing day having a
good hair day well I like I showered not
long before like I showered with enough
time for this to dry so yeah I got a I
got a hop over the discord really quick
see what questions came in over there so
just bear with me here folks let's see
hold on I am organized no I am NOT um
there it is do you think there will ever
be a big pushback against YouTube for
some of their recent policies I'm
talking youtubers actually leaving the
platform for something else
or have we reached a point where
everyone is content with just
complaining about the changes as they
happen
here's the thing YouTube is really
really embedded at this point it would
take a lot to disrupt YouTube I'm not
gonna say it's impossible but it's
something it's not something that's
gonna happen suddenly there is not I
don't think ever gonna be a mass exodus
of creators off of YouTube on to
something else for one very simple
reason no other platform for video can
boast the growth potential and the
viewer base because that's the thing
the only people at this point who could
safely move off of YouTube are people
who have really loyal fan bases who will
follow them anywhere but anyone who
isn't that size if you want to grow you
need to be here because this is where
the viewers are this is this has the
algorithm that assuming it doesn't
completely screw you over is pushing
your content in front of people who are
more likely to want it this is where you
grow it's kind of like how itself with
launching patreon patreon is a great
place to build to you know find a way to
get support from your base but you can't
grow your platform on patreon you can
direct people who like your stuff to
your patreon but patreon itself as a
platform nobody goes on patreon starts
just searching for stuff and it's the
same thing with video the alternatives
out there things like Vimeo nobody goes
to Vimeo to search around and see what
there is but they come to YouTube to do
that so you can't really grow on other
platforms all you can do is take
whatever fully if you try take whatever
view or base you have with you if you
try and migrate but you can't grow
elsewhere right now see scary a single
scene in Doctor Who revived era well I'm
gonna cheat and say midnight because
basically from the point at which the
doctor comes back from the cabin right
through the final scene with him Madonna
it is one
continuous scene so they're interesting
that you're not that you're a fan of the
dream Lord but not the valley are given
that they're both expressions of the
doctors dark impulses the thing about
the valley I find the valley art at this
point to be overly complicated in terms
of his existence and how he came about
and how people wanted to come back he's
like what I like about the dream Lord is
he's nice and simple dark side of the
doctor he got hit with this thing that
kind of brought that out of him
and if something else ever did that we
could have him back the simpler
explanation makes it easier to bring him
back without a lot of technobabble or
over complicated nonsense which is what
I'm a it's a big part of why I'm not
thrilled about the idea of the value at
ever coming back we're gonna be saddled
with a lot of junk to explain who he is
and why he's there and the dream Lord
doesn't need that as far as I'm
concerned the valley ARDS story's
concluded after beat finishes the last
adventure yeah I haven't heard that one
so I couldn't I couldn't tell you my
thoughts on that and he was some for
anyone attempting to start their own
channel yeah
figure out something that you will enjoy
doing no matter what both you know
topics format whatever it is have it be
something that you will take some
satisfaction and enjoyment out of doing
even if nobody watches because odds are
that nobody will be at the very least
for quite a while I took five years to
get to a thousand subscribers and I
wouldn't have kept doing this if I
didn't just enjoy it as a thing so you
know you you really have to you really
have to like doing this because if you
come in with a goal of just growing and
getting big you're treating it like a
job and it can become a job and if it
ever does become a job you should
probably treat it like one but if you
treat it like a job when you're just
starting out you're never gonna enjoy it
enough to get it to the point where it
could be a job
have you ever heard of a mockumentary
film called this is spinal tap of course
like has anyone not heard of spinal tap
or is it just cuz it's like at this
point and it's an old film and I feel
like Tony Stark listening to spider-man
going hey have you ever seen that really
old movie called The Empire Strikes Back
Sonny and mighty
[Music]
would you consider reviewing the
existing TMNT movies and/or shows ah no
because like I'm so out of the loop on
that stuff right now I do want to I do
want to watch Batman versus TMNT I do
want to find the time to do that but
like the the shows and the the constant
reboots of the shows and the films of
like no you ever seen Scott Pilgrim vs.
the world and if so what did you think I
enjoyed it at the time I saw it I
haven't rewatched it in a long time
because as time has gone on I have I
found more and more issue with a lot of
the approach and sort of subtext and
mentality of the characters I don't like
a lot of these people and I don't like
how a lot of these relationships are
framed by the narrative it's a good
movie and it's incredibly well executed
for what it is but my my my thoughts I
have softened over the years did your
daughter take you take up your offer on
a hill to rewatch sadly no she didn't
but I think I I think I rewatched a
lighter episode of Shira to bring myself
back up movies that everyone raves about
that you can't stand I'll do that as a
video list eventually I mean the big
obvious one for me is the shining more
recently the first it I love your
reviews but I have to be honest I felt
you a review of reign of Superman wasn't
to be too harsh
I felt the
Payne the movie caused me to be too
harsh so you know potato potato
after watching your reviews I finally
caught up on Shira my hope for season
four Hordak learns the truth about and
trap to capture did them wrong
how contra is cactus burning every
bridge everywhere like whenever the show
ends whatever season it is at some point
whether it's how she ends up at the very
very end but it's somewhat catcher is
going to be completely alone cuz that is
the path she is on and the last one
who's gonna be by her side before she's
totally alone is gonna be scorpion and
eventually scorpy is going to realize
that she is never going to care about
her as much as she cares about Katra and
for her self-preservation she'll walk
away and catch all will be alone and
she'll have done it to herself are you
looking forward to the steamy universe
TV movie I sell really seen any of
Steven universe scandal to be fair the
reign of Superman comic was strange and
disjointed compiling it into a concise
narrative must have been a nightmare I
would agree with that except that at
this point I don't feel the strength or
weakness or length or whatever of the
original source material is a valid
defense of any of those things because
there are massively complicated stories
that have made great animated films look
at new frontier you ever read that thing
it's this friggin thick they made a
brilliant film out of it
death of Superman while a much simpler
story than random the Superman it's also
not good but they made a great movie out
of it Raina the Superman yeah it's
complicated but if they put more thought
into it they could have streamlined it a
lot of the stuff I didn't
like was like really had nothing to do
with the source material it was just
stupid a lot of stuff going on was just
dumb on its face regardless of what the
source material was so I I'm not trying
to get on that Rand again
hey there Kaylee what's your guilty
pleasure movie um I mean probably I mean
first of all I don't actually do guilty
pleasures I like what I like and I don't
apologize for it but a couple of movies
that I like that most people think are
dumb and stupid and bad the the Masters
of the Universe movie GI Joe Rise of
Cobra and the house on Haunted Hill from
99 with Geoffrey Rush all movies that
like people like oh that was dumb like I
love that I thought reign of the
Superman was fine great I'm glad you
liked him more than me I'm not I'll
never be mad at someone for liking
something how honestly more often than
not I'll be jealous I wish I had gotten
something out of it you did good on you
not me though it's not that it was
complicated the comic was just a mess I
barely had a plot after the set up
beyond the cyborg is the evil one okay
so then why adapted at all that becomes
an argument to not even adapt that as a
piece of source material not a defense
of the thing that they made would you
recommend the Shearer a reboot oh god
yes I love that thing it's just that
none of the scenes I've seen from the
show impressed to be honest though I
don't hate it just not excited I mean it
your mileage may vary it depends on what
appeals to you for me and my
sensibilities I love it
I absolutely love it but like it's not
for everybody nothing is have you heard
the rumors that Matt Smith will be
playing Palpatine in the new Star Wars
no I only heard that whatever character
he was playing has been cut from the
film that I heard that's happened to him
a few times
okay so let me pop on back to the
discord real quick is the fact that
there are new content outlets that I
know besides YouTube one of the reasons
why you to feels they the fact that
there are a few content outlets besides
YouTube one of the reasons YouTube feel
they can make sweeping changes and not
always favorable policy changes I mean
it's it's part of the reason that they
don't have to massively worry about what
creators think now they can't completely
screw us over because it would if they
if they if they are too callous and to
poisonous towards creators they they can
poison the well and people might start
abandoning out of spite at this point
whatever problems YouTube has they're
not big enough to make it worth
abandoning the potential audience size
cuz like I said you can't really grow on
any other platforms as they currently
exist well what are your experiences
with claims on your video doesn't impact
your plans on video si um so my
experience with claims have been varied
so some studios are just awful about it
and some of them are pretty chilled
Disney's pretty chill Warner Brothers is
pretty chill
BBC can go either way um but when they
decide to get a bug up there but they're
really bad um Fox has been a pain I
don't know I eventually I expect those
often because they've now been acquired
by Disney but during the first chunk of
these sorts of transitions there
usually operated as they have been so
that's probably still not very bad and
then you know paramount can just go
straight to hell so it's uh it's it's a
variety of things my experience for the
most part most copyright claims issued I
have successfully fought on the basis of
fair use there have been a couple where
the copyright holder did not capitulate
because most of them if you say hey fair
use they'll back off but some of them
won't they'll still say no we're still
claiming this which is what the BBC did
with my barrier queers video does it
impact how I approach video essays yes
it does because it does impact what
impacts both the writing in the editing
stages because what I am going to use as
a point of reference changes so like
I've got one that I'm trying to I'm
trying to double-check who has the
copyright on all the clips I want to use
for it to make sure that they're
gnarling the people that I know are
problems and I might have to roll the
dice on some that I don't really know so
yeah it does actually impact things
because there are just some people I
don't want to mess with and like it's
not even just the video essays when I
review a paramount movie
I won't even show an image like I I have
Joel my guy who does the thumbnails he
uses that image not available thing when
I review air mount movies
that's how better I am with those jerks
if you could completely remove any
doctor episode from Canon other than
hell-bent Wells like other than how bent
that the thing is like other Bad
episodes don't have bigger implications
by their badness so like fear her is an
awful episode but I don't feel the need
to remove them from Canon cuz it doesn't
its badness doesn't spread out and
affect anything else hell-bent is kind
of unique in that way and that the ways
in which it's bad have ripple effects if
that's really not the case with almost
anything else so I'm not sure there's
anything I would remove other than
hell-bent happy I didn't miss all the
stream haze nd air nice to see ya
remove kill the moon I've never had as
big an issue with kill the moon as other
people did I'm really curious as to what
I'll think of it when I get to it on the
rewatch I'm away I'm a ways off from
that one though
what Doctor Who character would you like
to have as a roommate um I mean Craig
seems chill and accommodating feeling
that maybe Mickey I gonna pop on back to
the discord real quick let's see dude do
you not YouTube related but this one's
in here how old were you when you had
your first relationship I started dating
when I was 16 so sophomore year of high
school who was your inspiration for
starting youtube on nobody initially
because if you go way back to the start
of this channel it was scripted shorts
and was in born no resemblance to what
it is now initially I just fell on
YouTube by default because it was free
and I could upload the stuff and I had
this friggin you know series of shorts
in my head I've had it for a few years
and I just needed to do it and be done
with it so that I knew
was I knew I'd done it and I could move
on and start doing other things
one of the major inspirations for the
format that I started doing which was me
writing at the camera a was Jeremy Jones
and also Chris stuckman to a certain
extent but you know after a while I III
haven't really liked deliberately taken
inspiration from somebody from anybody a
while there are probably unconscious
inspirations that I'm not I don't even
clock in my head at this point but you
know that's that's hard to track for
obvious reasons what is your opinion of
Man of Steel I haven't rewatched it
since the first time I saw it I remember
thinking at the time I don't like what
this is but it's a decent enough version
of what it is chosen to be if that makes
sense
my guilty pleasures are Superman 3 and
before Wow way more watchable tusu
Superman Returns
that's bold we haven't had a good
Superman movies since - unless you count
the animated films like the elite I was
gonna say have you seen all the anime
films because some of them are quite
good All Star Superman's another really
good one designing women' drops on hulu
in five days so excited I never got into
that one Golden Girls I like that that's
good show what's your opinion on the
thief and the cobbler I still haven't
seen it buy any version of it I would
like to the story behind that thing is
fascinating but I haven't seen any
version of that still have you stopped
using nail polish why no I haven't stop
the thing is I'm I'm not out of my job
and so I don't wear nail polish during
the week I wear it on weekends so it
shows up in any video that I happen to
shoot on a weekend or otherwise a day
that I have off but you know I I have to
well I don't have to I
choose to take it off for my job
strictly speaking you know there are
legal protections for gender identity
where I work but I worked at a
conservatively minded company stopped by
conservatively minded people in a
conservative area it's it's not a matter
of they don't let me do this
I don't feel comfortable being out at
work so that's why I don't have the the
nail polish on as much as I would like
to to be completely honest about it I
mean it's one of its it's one of the
things that I tend to think about you
know if I can ever build this thing to
the point of you know between this and
and patreon and I don't know if I can
get some other books published you know
that this becomes my living if I can
ever get to that point that'll be
amazing and one of the reasons I I look
forward to that as a possibility has not
unimaginable but like a lot of leg work
to do before I could get there as it may
be not having to hide anymore as one of
them because my job is basically the
last significant part of my life that
I'm not out and open which sucks cuz
that's forty hours of my week not to
mention a lot of those gender identity
protections have been very quietly
vanishing under the current
administration well this is a state
protection so it's not under federal
protections the the state that I work
and has state level protections for
gender identity so the BS going on at
the federal level doesn't impact that
but I also know enough about HR and
everything else to know that that
doesn't that only protects you so much
because it just gives a reason that
they're not allowed to fire you but the
simple truth is if
if I started being out and open and
having Neapolitan and wearing dangly
earrings and going in with lipstick they
couldn't strictly speaking fire me
because of that but if I started doing
that and the people I work for were
uncomfortable with it they could find a
reason to get rid of me even if
ultimately they just say oh well we're
eliminating your position we're not
firing you we're just cutting the job so
you know what can you do there are
plenty of ways they could get rid of me
if I was making people uncomfortable by
my presence they just couldn't fire me
specifically because of that companies
find reasons though I don't drink
alcohol being Muslim and all but Golden
Girls has aged well like fine wine yes
it has actually was a shockingly well I
would say cuz a lot of comedies eighties
era especially like a lot of that humor
is aged Golden Girls holds up really
well it's still really funny it's really
nice and like all the characters are
great there's a reason to love
absolutely all of them but over the
years I've taken a particularly like to
how much pride Blanche takes in and I'm
only gonna use this word because they
use it in the show and she practically
self identifies as this heard her
tendencies to be a [ __ ] she's not only
unashamed of it she takes pride in it
like I remember Dorothy at one point
saying that Rose was the biggest [ __ ] in
the home and lace goes Dorothy Zbornak
you take that back and it was it was
great or whatever II think she's talking
with her mother who has dementia and
like gets her kids confused and she's
like she's sharing a story with her
mother hey remember this and her mother
goes you know confuse her with her with
her other kids you guys I don't
understand wasn't different Virginia the
[ __ ] and place goes no ma'am that was me
said with utter pride I don't love that
oh that's such a good show
is the Golden Girls set the same as
French Britain Fresh Prince of bel-air
not that I know of I mean it's possible
was maybe shot on the same lot but
that's not the same thing condoms Rose
condoms come and I have to wonder if the
fact that I have now said the word [ __ ]
like four times is now gonna get this
this demonetized when I archive it I bet
you it will ah have you watched the boys
I gotta have that to the list of drink
questions no I haven't I might
eventually but like I'm not a huge fan
of Garth Ennis who wrote the original
comic so I'm that has not been a
priority if you could collaborate with
any youtuber who would you want to do
videos with and why oh okay
so like if I'm going with somebody who I
haven't worked with already because
obviously I would love to do something
with to bankfull again and there are
some people who I have reached out and
talked to that I want to try and do
stuff with and I've now done stuff with
crispy Pro and a scraper but if we could
if we could find something to like merge
together on I'd love to do something
with passion of the nerd I'm not like
gonna go like shoot for the moon of like
oh I want to do something that is in
some way collaborate with contra points
and folding ideas like no those people
are way out of my league like the idea
of me even saying that is ridiculous but
yeah like something something like like
passion of the nerd or actually channel
pup I think I'd be fun to do something
with if I ever get the chance and I
probably could the problem with all
these things is always finding the time
because you have to find an opening your
schedules you have to pair what you're
gonna do you have to figure out if
you're gonna you're gonna script it or
if it's gonna be a live discussion how
you're gonna format it it's surprisingly
complicated
mr. TARDIS I mean yeah I'd be up for it
the only Garth Ennis comic I read was
hitman because I enjoyed the characters
and as showed his appreciation for
Superman and that one issue I liked
enos's early work with Punisher like I
like welcome home Frank I don't like
some of the later stuff that he did with
punish I also like Punisher born which
was him but some of the later stuff he
did with Punisher I didn't love and
preacher I gave up volume three or four
it was four I walked away from preacher
on because what I've always said about
Garth Ennis is the man is about 70
percent as clever as he thinks he is he
is clever he's not dummy writes well but
he's he's he's not as clever as he
thinks he is and that comes across to me
and that was really starting to even get
me as I got as I started to get further
further into preacher maybe which is why
I had to I had to bail on it I knew here
hello there
gotta go but big love for everyone oh
thank you very much what other
representation in media identities would
you like to explore in the future oh
well like I've actually already shot a
video on none on non binary
representation so that's in the can
Wow shooting is in the can I need to
edit it and that's actually gonna be a
bit of a beast because that conversation
went on a long time and I think for it
to flow best I need to rearrange certain
parts of it so that's that's actually
gonna be an intimidating piece and that
is gonna be if I can nail it down
that'll be next month that comes out
after that I don't know I mean there's
plenty more fur for me to look into it I
think it's largely a question of who I
can find to talk to about some of it how
do you feel about the Shazam movie I I
saw haven't seen it so your question
about the specific element I do
no cuz I have not seen it did you get
the chance to watch Braeburn nope did
not come out around me hold on I'm gonna
hop back to the discord real quick
what's subgenres apart from who Tube do
you watch um like here on YouTube there
it's mostly it's mostly movie related
stuff that I watch
so like I'm still subscribed to Jeremy
Jones and I'm I follow up Bob Shipman
because I think his his stuff is well
done out and I initially found Patrick
Williams and folding ideas through their
stuff on movies but you know I've got
I've got I've got a bit of a bread Tube
diet as well if you know what that is
[Music]
and like a limited amount of video game
stuff Jim sterling Yahtzee crow Shaw I
don't have I don't like have a dedicated
font or sub-genre
I like find specific people who I like
kind of no matter what they're talking
about and that's sort of the thing when
I subscribe to someone it's usually
because it's usually more about I like
you and less about I like the subject
you're talking about which is why
they'll there are times where I'll watch
a video like I agree or like thought was
really interesting all the things that
person said but something about them
whether it's the their vocal delivery or
what-have-you just wasn't clicking for
me and I won't keep following them it's
not because they aren't good it's just
because I didn't click with the
presenter I mean ultimately that's what
I need I'm the same with podcasts do you
watch film joy videos I'm not familiar
with that one you got bread build um no
because most of the stuff that folks who
are considered to be bread Tube tend to
talk about with stuff I was pretty much
already on board with so the whole
implication of bread pills you know to
do it as a parallel to red pills or
anything of that nature is to imply eyes
open and life changed I'm like no I'm
pretty much there for the most part
already hmm ah water do you listen to
the other team team whom and I've hi gas
or just improvised with weapons right
now it's just improvised weapons I keep
meaning to check out their other stuff
and not getting around to put are you
looking forward to the Netflix new Dark
Crystal heck yes oh my god yes I'm very
excited for that any channels you aren't
subscribed to still watch a fair amount
of um I'm not subscribed to like Seth
Meyer with whatever his show is um but
his stuff will still come up with my
recommendations and about 50 50 percent
of the time I I will watch it or another
thing like I mentioned this on Twitter
I've been falling down a rabbit hole
lately with videos from Penn & Teller
fool us and there isn't one channel for
that because mostly it's the actual
magicians whose tricks were performed on
their putting it up on their own
personal channels so I'm jumping all
over these channels to see these things
when does it cross the line between your
own personal morals or the general idea
of the morality of the channel itself
when controlling content um I'm not I'm
not entirely sure what you mean by
controlling content Gabe that sounds
like an interesting question but I'm not
entirely sure I understand what it is
you're asking do you watch Tom ignoble
the dami compares books on their moody
movie adaptations on occasionally odd on
occasionally have another drink on
occasion I have I haven't like done a
real dive into his back catalogue but I
liked what I've seen so far a meaning
how adult can you get on that channel
okay so are you asking for me or like my
thoughts on other people's channels like
for me I I really make an effort to stay
family-friendly because I don't
any of the topics I'm discussing should
be off-limits to to an all-ages audience
so I try and I try and always approach
stuff from an all-ages perspective yeah
that's me with my own stuff I love
contra boring that's Natalie is awesome
yeah she is and she's she's amazingly
just open and very honest in a way that
never feels like I'm letting you in on
my leg but we get little glimpses she
she has a lot of she puts a lot of
herself into this and it's very upfront
in discussions about things that yeah a
lot of people in her position wouldn't
talk about which I appreciate okay
should the topic be specific or based on
your own moral values I don't I'm sorry
Gabe I really feel like I'm not I'm not
fully grasping what it is you're you're
getting at with these questions I mean
it if you're asking do it do I think
people should only have more a more
adult content style approach for stuff
for stuff that is already adult content
well no you talk about whatever you want
to talk about however you want to talk
about it for the most part you know
within reason but I feel like you're
asking something specific and I'm just
not understanding the question which I
feel bad about to be completely honest
what was the first movie you remember
seeing in theaters the first one it
actually was the first movie that I saw
in theaters which was the Care Bears
movie this is the very first movie I
ever saw in theaters I don't remember
like the whole experience but I remember
like bits moments be in the theater yet
not Gabe you you basically just asked
the same question again with like one or
two words changed I'm I'm not
understanding I just I don't understand
what you're asking
I I if anyone can translate that cuz I
feel like I want to answer it but I just
I don't I don't get the question and I'm
sorry I feel like I feel like an asshat
for that but have you seen any of uh
moving mind studio stuff Ryan George's
sketch team I haven't seen a sketch team
stuff I've seen his own he's another one
who I don't subscribe to him but I do
like pop up on his I do click on his
stuff when it pops up in my
recommendations I do enjoy his things
overall what's your favorite thing about
being a youtuber um having an outlet
that people seem to actually want to
take in what I'm putting down or pick up
what I'm putting down taking what I'm
putting down sounds possibly dirty um
but you know whatever you want to do
with what I'm putting down I suppose but
you ask someone with a lot of creative
ambitions my biggest fear is always I
put work and time and you know effort
and thought and creativity into
something and then nobody reads it
watches it listens to it whatever it may
be that's always my biggest fear and one
of the main reasons I've been able to
get a bit better about that and I'm
actually now working towards
working on getting my novel published is
because I at this point I have a
reliable outlet that I can come to that
I know that I can talk about something
that people will want to hear it and
just being heard when you'd read that
nobody cares about what you have to say
is a very very powerful thing and I've
gotten that through this platform and
I'll always be grateful for that
looking back on Doctor Who series 11 a
lot of the detractors and defenders over
exaggerate the whole thing and weren't
objective about it at all it was an
average season I take it as a whole I
would say it's actually a below average
season but the episodes that are good in
it are really good I just feel that
there are actually fewer really good
episodes than is standard for Doctor Who
but now I it's both its strengths and
its issues are greatly exaggerated by
either side don't feel bad thanks Gabe I
appreciate that thank you for letting me
off the hook a little bit my bf and I
are rewatching Harry Potter along with
you we're enjoying your breakdowns great
hi next one of those is next week cuz
that's that's every two weeks for those
do you watched or monster them I don't
know so I guess that's a that's a no
have you ever seen cyber six Japanese
Canadian Argentinian cartoon from the
90s nope
and nah not familiar with that one do
you have an opinion on using your real
name as opposed to scream name one
beginning an online presence an opinion
no just do whatever you're comfortable
doing I have no judgment on anybody
going either direction on that do you
believe it's important as a critic I
thank you for putting critic in quotes
oh geez Passion of the nerd crap uh to
be engaging your own creative and enters
like writing or is the art of criticism
enough um
yeah Roger Ebert did write valley of the
dolls I would I would say it's not a
requirement it's not a barrier to entry
like I I would never make a statement
like you have no right to criticize
until you've tried to do the same thing
but I do think getting stuck in to the
process of trying to create something
can give you a better insight as to
where and how things go really right or
go really wrong from the creation side
of it now that said I think people who
don't have any background in that or any
ambition to that are still perfectly
capable of delivering very well-done
critique but it's gonna be much more on
the experiential side and not
necessarily having the knowledge of how
the thing was created now again that
does mean you can't critique it because
you know it's the old thing I may not
know art but I know what I like it has
an opinion and as long as you are able
to express that in a way that is cogent
and and makes sense to people and people
connect with that's fine
but I do find it interesting that
virtually all of the critics or people
who produce in some way critical
material seem to also pursue their own
creative endeavors there's a few of them
who I don't know if they do but
virtually all of them that I know that I
really really like seem to and I'm not
sure if that's necessarily something
that points to you should definitely do
this
but at least for the kind of criticism
that I enjoy they seem to go hand in
hand we'll go with that I've been making
YouTube videos for over six years and
haven't made a penny but I'm still going
today because it's just pure fun in my
opinion and that
great cuz like that's rule number one
enjoy doing it because if you don't why
are you here it's not always fun it can
be work but like at the end of the day
underneath it you need to be able to sit
back and go am I happy I spent my time
doing that yes yes I am thank you keep
doing it what was your opinion on an
umbrella Academy I like to pretty well
um I didn't I didn't love Vanya --zz
storyline and where it went but overall
was pretty good I really liked five and
I really liked Klaus and I really liked
hazel those were sort of a highlights
for me I consider Prisoner of Azkaban to
be the only genuinely great Harry Potter
movie do you agree - or disagree yeah I
absolutely disagree I'll get to it when
I talk about the movie but Prisoner of
Azkaban is my favorite book in the
series it is not my favorite movie in
the series and I shall explain that in
more detail when I get to it
yay ah our critics better at taking
criticism no you think so
and that's not to say that all critics
like have thin skin but like I suspect
you get the same percentage of people
who can take criticism and can't in the
feet of the criticisms add with almost
anything else so I don't think they're
any better or worse inherently do you
have third parties reuploading your
content and how do you handle it if so
take downs or let it be to the best of
my knowledge nobody is reloading my
content at least not on YouTube if it's
getting up reuploaded on other platforms
somewhere else I'm not gonna take the
time to deal with that cuz it's not it's
not siphoning off anything from here
YouTube's up it's free to view you know
why would anyone go to some
weird other things so if anyone's
reuploading my stuff on YouTube I don't
know about it if I ever find out about
it I don't know I'll figure out what I'm
gonna do about it yeah that would be a
purely hypothetical issue for me at this
point favorite Fawlty Towers episode I
mean it's it's hard not not to love Zee
Germans episode they're all really good
though I should wrap it up soon cuz I've
actually I've got editing to do that
that spider-man video that I that I
mentioned is gonna be out tomorrow I
have shop but I need to edit let's see
I'm gonna pop back to the discord real
quick
have you seen pitch meeting series on
screen ramp with Ryan George I have not
all of them but I have seen a fair
amount
my son is wanting to do YouTube but says
his only software is moviemaker and has
no idea how to get started ie planning
out content etc any advice I can't
really give me too much advice on movie
makers specifically because I've never
used it like wow that's not true like
some of the first few videos I put up on
the veer a wild channel I did with movie
maker
um but god that was ages and ages and
ages and ages ago
so I can't give you any advice on that
as an editing software or using it as
far as planning things out I mean it
depends on what he wants to do like I
would I would advise against anyone just
starting out to over plan because
honestly at least in my experience you
will learn best by doing and the biggest
mistake that anyone in any creative film
is field and yes content creation on
YouTube is a creative field even if it's
critique even if it's commentary and
criticism of other people's work this is
still a creative endeavor the biggest
mistake people in any creative field
make is trying to is spending all their
time thinking about what they're gonna
do and never doing it it's why it's the
old cliche
that you know everybody and you know
sitting on a laptop in a coffee shop is
an unpublished screenwriter or you know
everyone has the Great American Novel
that book in their head that they like
Oh that'd be great but they never
actually sit down and write it I think
the best thing you can do is not get too
ambitious at the start start with very
simple ideas and they can be ridiculous
they can be stupid they can be saying it
could be something that you're like I
have no idea this all work start small
start simple develop a rhythm get used
to the equipment get used to the camera
get used to the editing software
don't try and don't try and be Orson
Welles don't try and make Citizen Kane
as your first project start basic work
your way up so if if these getting hung
out on where to start or what to plan
then my initial thought is ease thinking
too hard about it one more off the
discord do you think you'll be doing a
lot Let's Plays of any other games in
the future or as new-found encourages
only when you're planning on
experimenting this style with a newfound
courage is is obviously the first of
these that I'm doing it'll depend partly
on response but obviously like that this
is a this is a niche indie game I'm not
expecting huge response on it I've been
pretty happy with it so far I'm thinking
about some other possibilities um part
of it like it's never gonna be something
I'm gonna do oh new game just came out
I'm gonna do that like no if I do it
it's gonna be on a limited basis and
very very very selectively so like an
example of something that I'm thinking
about maybe I'll do is I just recently
got and completed my first playthrough
on Bastion um which I loved and I really
want to check out some of the other
games from the developer from supergiant
games so maybe I'll try a let's play of
train
sister or pyre you know one of their one
of the things they've made since Bastian
but it would be that kind of thing it
would be it would be something shorter
it would be something that I could
basically a full playthrough would be
three to four hours and not be something
that's gonna require me to learn twitch
reflexes cuz I don't have I don't have
gamer muscle memory anymore but we'll
see it's possible and I do need to wrap
it up soon well it's the best video game
for streaming Tony I have no idea that's
good advice I'm trying to be a writer
though I'm 39 so I'm too old darn your
real life so your advice is helpful you
are never too old to write you're never
too old to start doing any creative
endeavor however old you are
first of all if you're 39 you're only
two years older than I am
first off so thanks for that um but
beyond that you never - you're never too
old you are never too old to start doing
the thing you want to do with your life
whether that is writing a book whether
that is doing YouTube whether that is
trying your hand a stand up comedy
whether it's learning to sing play the
piano as long as you have the physical
capability of doing it and even if you
don't there's workarounds for a lot of
stuff just do it the excuse of I'm too
old
it's a rationalization that we can fall
into I'm thinking I missed my window
it's like no make your own window
thank you very much Nina much
appreciated I wrote my first book and
it's on Amazon congratulations
never
might I felt old already I'm 39 but I
just want to get nothing to understand
what my question was a pap well I mean
like maybe you're being too ambitious
there but you know um no one gave me
like maybe we can bang it out on the
discord and I can address it next
livestream if I can wrap my head
completely around it after that rousing
speech I'm gonna sit down and write out
the story I've been thinking about for
your good good
I'm 33 I just finished a drama degree
started doing guitar lessons awesome I
halfway through writing a book it's
about the super geeky topic of
typography fantastic oh I've been trying
to write a book series among other
interests yes yes every guess do the
thing whatever is the thing that you
want to do or you started and I've been
gotten back to yet do the thing I'm
trying to do the thing like I said I'm
I'm actually working on seeing my novel
work through hopefully I'll have that
ready for next year and we'll see that
you know what that actually might be
next week's topic you know writing
creative great creativity working on a
novel for as long as I have because I've
been working on this thing ever
I think that'll probably be next week's
topic but for now we do have to wrap up
cuz I have to edit so thanks everybody
for tuning in this has been a lot of fun
how much do you know about HP Lovecraft
um enough to know that you need to be
willing to overlook a lot of textual and
subtextual issues with his work some of
the time
have you seen intimidation game I have
not yet so love love your videos thank
you very much any tips for proper
representation been doing a video a
month for over a year
addressing issues of proper
representation
so I don't have a simple answer to bang
off out in the last few minutes alright
so everybody have a great night
thank you for tuning in this has been
fun as it always is so thanks everybody
for the support the love the kindness
listening talking working do your thing
whatever it is go and do it and remember
that you are beautiful you are loved you
are valid
you are the council I just run these
meetings